liberal republicans remain completely
clueless they go along with it
they provide limp opposition and then
ultimately
they acquiesce to the true rulers of the
country
the bureaucracy you saw this with the
liberal republican governor
larry hogan larry hogan big old lib
larry hogan comes out and he says you
need to wear
a mask you need to listen to dr fauci
sure we can pretend to be republicans
but you ultimately need to listen to our
technocratic scientific
egghead overlords if you don't do that
you you're basically
guilty of murder well it's it's sort of
like saying
i have a constitutional right to drive
drunk
i have a constitutional right to not
wear a seat belt
or to yell fire in a crowded movie
theater
uh or to not follow the speed limit uh
it's you know we're talking about a
quarter of a million people dying
already you know more than you know the
the
the korean war the gulf war and vietnam
were added together
uh which part don't you understand you
wear the mask it's there's no
constitutional right
to walk around without a mask this is we
did it in in
1918. i don't know why we can't do it
now
first of all no we didn't have
nationwide mass mandates in 1918.
how stupid does this guy think we are
but more we also didn't have a
technocratic
administrative apparatus in 1918 that
was actually governing us
through the mouthpieces of governors
including liberal republicans like larry
hogan
but but more than that not wearing a
mask is like driving drunk
show me those death rates buddy i don't
i don't think that's true
all the experts were telling us that we
shouldn't wear masks
what five six months ago now they're
telling us we should wear masks
and who knows what they'll tell us
tomorrow studies coming out
questioning the effectiveness of the
masks doesn't matter doesn't matter
whatever is convenient
to our technocratic overlords
now what's funny about this everyone's
attacking larry hogan for this including
me
but i actually think he's on to a little
something when he says look
we you don't have a right to yell fire
in a crowded theater which is an
extraordinarily overused example but it
gets to what we were saying earlier
there are limits
on well on everything because this is a
limited bounded world
from the very beginning of our country
all the way to the present there have
been huge swaths of speech we're not
allowed to say
there's been plenty of things that we're
not allowed to do i used to be very
frustrated by this as a little kid
back when people still said but this is
a free country remember when kids would
say that
and i would say i'd say wait what do you
mean there's a speed limit this is a
free country what do you mean there's a
traffic light this is a free country
but of course i had a childish view of
freedom
which a lot of people have today and
what is what the founding fathers had is
an adult view of freedom
an exalted freedom a freedom in ordered
liberty a freedom in justice
freedom that uh does not just have us
pursuing our appetites willy-nilly but a
freedom that gives us the right to do
what we ought to do
i hope you enjoyed that short segment
from the michael knowles show be sure to
check out the full
episode linked in the description or
download the podcast
wherever you listen to podcasts
[Music]
[Music]